[Musique]
mais non jacob lebel appelle ses vaches
en ce matin brumeux et frisquet à
roseburg en oregon
ce québécois d'origine vit depuis l'âge
de 4 ans sur la ferme familiale
ses parents ont émigré sur la côte ouest
américaine
bean bag alliés l'élu belle vivent des
produits de la terre en harmonie avec la
nature
j'ai grandi sur cette ferme avec
certaines valeurs un cuir la valeur
simple protéger notre environnement
le réchauffement du climat menace leur
mode de vie
la saison de feu a augmenté d'à peu près
21 jours dans les années 1970 à au
dessus de 116 jours maintenant
jacob est un des 21 jeunes américains
qui poursuivent en justice le
gouvernement des états unis
il dénonce l'inaction des élus et les
meilleurs scientifiques ils ont toutes
les ressources pour trouver des
solutions
je peux pas croire que qui peuvent pas
prendre des actions pour arrêter nous
mettre en danger
qu'ainsi giuliana est un autre des
visages de cette poursuite contre l'état
le plus puissant de la planète
la cause porte d'ailleurs son nom
giuliana contre le gouvernement
américain
l'administration de chambre se défend
bec et ongle cassé en a c'est de la
négligence environnementale de ses aînés
[Musique]
julian chine l'avocate des jeunes
accusent l'état de tenir deux discours
un an public et l'autre devant les juges
le chercheur hugo séguin fait son
doctorat en éthique environnementale à
l'université de l'oregon
ils appuient la cause des jeunes c'est
qu'elle donne un point d'entrée à toute
une génération pour saisir nos lancers
c'est ma cause
à moi et vous mal est vrai pas mon ami
de l'autre côté du pays en floride
li vaille 11 ans est le plus jeune des
requérants de cette poursuite
l'île de sainte-hélène beach tout près
de cap canaveral et son terrain de jeu
il est inquiet pour sa plage et les
espèces qui vivent une algue toxique a
provoqué une marée rouge dans ce coin de
la floride dans les derniers mois
un désastre dû entre autres aux
fertilisants et à la hausse des
températures dans l'atlantique ce qui
vient aussi l'action de ces jeunes est
nécessaire affirme hugo séguin
mais le temps presse si 2050
nos économies ici dans les grands pays
industrialisés devront tête à toutes les
pratiques décarboniser alors ça veut
dire qu'il y reste plus beaucoup de
temps
si on veut être à la hauteur de l'enjeu
il n'est jamais trop tard expliqué c'est
julian à quatorze juges affirme-t-elle
ont déjà rejeté les arguments des
avocats du gouvernement américain en
mars
jacob lebel espère encore vivre
longtemps en oregon malgré la menace des
feux nous sommes tous dit il
dans cette course contre la montre tu
peux être un étudiant tu peux être un
écrivain type est un artiste un fermier
un ingénieur il a des manières de créer
un meilleur monde pour nous tous le
peut-il y vas y fais du réchauffement
climatique
un combat de tous les jours une bataille
qu'il veut gagner pour sauver la planète
mais aussi sont ils
cette cause et surtout celle de ces
jeunes qui doivent maintenant réparer
les dégâts laissés par leurs années il
n'est peut-être pas trop tard mais leur
avenir portera toujours les traces des
négligences du passé
[Musique]